moving now to this on Thanksgiving Day
President Biden addressed the mass
shootings in Colorado and Virginia
earlier this month and he is now calling
for more strict gun laws
the idea the idea we still allow
semi-automatic weapons to be purchased
is sick this is sick it has no no social
media value zero none not a single
solitary rationale for it except profit
for the gun manufacturer can you do
anything about gun laws during the lame
Ducks I'm gonna try
the reality is legislative action on
guns will be more challenging when
Republicans take control of the house
come the New Year our Zhang is traveling
with the president on Nantucket Island
Massachusetts and she joins us now Ouija
good morning to you
good morning Errol and good morning to
everybody President Biden went on to
acknowledge that getting rid of assault
rifles of course depends on whether or
not he has the votes to pass legislation
and right now it does not appear that he
does the democratic-controlled house
passed a bill to ban assault weapons
earlier this year but with such a narrow
majority in the Senate the measure
hasn't had enough support to advance
over the summer the president did sign a
bill that expanded background checks and
added restrictions to who can purchase
firearms it also gave States incentives
to pass so-called red flag laws that
allow courts to remove weapons from
people who are considered a threat to
themselves or others yesterday President
Biden also spoke with the owners of club
Q in Colorado Springs that is the lgbtq
plus nightclub where a gunman killed
five people and injured 17 others last
weekend President Biden and the first
lady offered condolences and reaffirmed
their support for the community Michelle
Ouija thank you